[Musica]
[Applauso]
però la butto lì e va benissimo di tasti
Adesso va meglio grazie
Ciao e benvenuti sul mio canale di
YouTube
oppure ci sono un po' di alternative
[Musica]
Ciao e benvenuti sul mio canale di
YouTube
Oppure ancora perché no
[Musica]
Ciao e benvenuti sul mio canale di
YouTube ora Ho una domanda per tutti
quanti voi
Secondo voi di questi tre strumentisti
che avete visto quindi nell'ordine
pianista chitarrista e beatboxer Quale
di questi tre ha maggiori probabilità
di venire riconosciuto sul web di farsi
notare Quale di questi potrebbe essere
il più virale diciamo
Allora utilizziamo un metodo un po'
arcaico che è l'applausometro fa molto
telemaiche degli anni 80 praticamente
dovrete applaudire solo ed
esclusivamente in concomitanza dello
strumentista che voi ritenete essere più
degno di attenzione molto semplice
quindi Cominciamo con il primo il
pianista secondo voi con un applauso
quanta possibilità il pianista rispetto
agli altri due fatemi sentire uno due
tre
[Applauso]
Ok non me l'aspettavo nettamente Ok
secondo il chitarrista Quante
possibilità ha Secondo voi di nuovo 1 2
è una bella lotta ma direi che ha
decisamente visto Hai vinto il
chitarrista e adesso arriviamo con il
terzo il beatboxer 1 2 3
ok
[Musica]
Avete deciso voi Quindi tecnicamente ha
vinto il beatboxer rispetto a questi tre
Se mi posso permettere di dare un umile
quanto inutile parere e vi posso dire
che cosa ne penso io secondo me di
questi tre quello che ha più possibilità
è
nessuno
non è una battuta nessuno nessuno di
questi tre ce la farà mai per un motivo
molto semplice quante volte Avete visto
questa cosa che fosse una chitarra un
Saxo quello che è 10 miliardi di volte
ci saranno qualcosa tipo 100.000 milioni
di metri quadrati di canali di gente che
fa la stessa identica cosa non ce la
farete mai così
stavo parlando con un mio amico di
Genova Tra l'altro un bassista preparato
ha studiato in accademia un sacco di
cose che però arranca un pochino con il
lavoro mi fa Sai Marco io sarò onesto un
po' ti invidio e già fa ridere così Però
vabbè ehm perché tu adesso vai in giro
va in tour Suoni la chitarra la tastiera
quello che è quello che ti serve con Ax
oppure quando non sei in tour sei su
YouTube hai la tua realtà consolidata
Quindi sei autonomo e di questi tempi
effettivamente mantenersi con la musica
è un po' una chimera effettivamente mi
si stringe il cuore quando sento questa
cosa perché ci siamo passati tutti in
questo inferno del musicista che non sa
cosa deve fare per fare qualcosa della
tua vita
e quindi io rispondo sempre con la
stessa domanda a questa domanda ed è ok
perfetto Andrea si chiama Andrea
esattamente Tu che cosa vuoi essere eh
riformulo la frase vuoi essere un
turnista Cioè praticamente tu vuoi
mettere a disposizione le tue conoscenze
il tuo basso per suonare per qualcun
altro oppure vuoi fare l'artista vuoi
creare la tua musica vuoi fare in modo
che tutto il tuo impegno sia fatto e sia
esclusivamente per il tuo progetto dimmi
sì
Aiutami e a me basta che mi dai uno
strumento e sono contento
e questa roba ti fa stringere ancora di
più il cuore perché questa roba come
dicevo la capisco benissimo C'è un sacco
di confusione D'altronde il nostro non è
un percorso lineare questo già lo sapete
se vai a studiare
ingegneria hai un'altra probabilità che
andrai a fare più o meno Qualche cosa
che ha a che fare con l'ingegneria
noi se andiamo a studiare musica abbiamo
effettivi tante possibilità di
sviluppare le nostre skill artigianali
per confezionare panini del McDonald's
Il punto è che questa cosa è normale la
sappiamo non ho scoperto di certo
l'acqua calda però funziona così e
quindi nascono delle domande Devo farvi
il Conservatorio devo saper leggere a
prima vista il mio spartito tutte queste
domande inconcludenti perché Perché
l'obiettivo L'obiettivo non è chiaro
torniamo al mio amico amico Io ti
conosco Sono anni che ti conosco e
quindi mi devi raccontare perché io so
che tu volevi fare un album tu volevi
fare un album Ma che punto sei Sono anni
che devi scrivere sto cazzo di album
Guarda
io ho delle bozze vado avanti scrivo
cose però poi torno indietro perché
qualcosa non mi convince c'è qualcosa
per esempio in questo brano qua non mi
piace la cassa
Ma che cazzo se ne frega della cassa ma
ora ma noi siamo questi Noi siamo i nerd
del Terzo Millennio noi passiamo tutta
la nostra vita a dire Oh sai cosa però
questa cassa Forse è meglio di questa ma
chi se ne frega è una cassa
arriva al dunque poi ci lamentiamo che
quelli che non sanno niente di musica
voglio fare nomi però
che non sono niente di musica non sanno
scrivere eccetera fanno dischi di
platino Eh grazie non sanno fare niente
Sì ma almeno hanno un'idea e la portano
a compimento No noi ci perdiamo delle
casse se vuoi fare il lavoro delle casse
vai a fare il produttore quindi questo
dilemma non esiste neanche più ma non è
questo il tuo problema perché tu vuoi
essere un artista E allora cosa fai
niente assolutamente niente fantastico
Wow siamo tutti fieri di te e e quindi
come come come fai a venirmi a capo da
una cosa del genere e dici Noi siamo dei
perfezionisti no noi non siamo dei
raramente siamo dei perfezionisti
Noi siamo insicuri e non ci concediamo
il privilegio dell'errore
Bet Food
Meglio sentire il dolore della scrittura
che il dolore della De non aver scritto
Faby World of Bridge una delle attrici
che più stimo nel mondo e ancora uno
script brutto È comunque meglio di uno
bello che non esiste ora Qua si sta
parlando di sceneggiature non di musica
ma il discorso è lo stesso pensiamo di
non essere mai pronti ma siamo pronti
adesso
anche voi che non suonate non so quanti
di voi suonano
scarsissima maggioranza figurati Però va
benissimo Il punto è che può anche
bastare una nota ragazzi una nota e
potete iniziare e finire una canzone ed
è esattamente quello che vado a
dimostrare adesso mi ha dato una parola
per favore parole
cinema cane
Boh puoi fare di meglio che che superi
le tre sillabe possibilmente
carta ok
sordo fantasia tristezza mi è arrivato
Ti ringrazio Ti voglio bene
fantastico Ok allora tristezza così
almeno te lo faccio vedere Non so
neanche dove sei Vabbè voi non lo vedete
ma loro sì allora come facciamo oggi io
sto per improvvisare una canzone da zero
Non so cosa succederà
ma sto per scrivere qui sul telefono la
tristezza
e poi lascerò all'auto completamente del
telefono la chiusura della frase Questo
sarà l'unico testo della mia canzone La
tristezza voi non lo vedete è
stata
fatta in casa
potrebbe essere una canzone Indie non ha
senso Vabbè tanto avrete capito Non mi
interessa il concetto il concetto Ce
l'avete voi il non importa il concetto
Ce l'avete voi e saprete voi che cosa
Dovrete dire
e adesso non lo so
Questa è la parte imprevedibile di
questa esibizione qua la tata
[Musica]
e adesso pian piano costruiamo la nostra
canzone magari non con la voce da Cip e
Ciop però la costruiamo
[Musica]
ok
e a poco a poco Costruiamo questo brano
c'è anche questo simpatico limite di una
nota che non è semplicissimo e in realtà
Infatti ho appena infranto la regola Le
note sono due
[Musica]
E adesso cosa avevamo detto la tristezza
è stata
fatta in casa Perfetto
La sì
[Musica]
Ok ok Chi l'avrebbe detto che avrei
trasformato il tedesco in un rave
Praticamente però è vero
in realtà sembra che da questo discorso
io stia dicendo se non studiate fate
meglio No no
perché studiare è quello che se mai ti
consente di non dire la tristezza è
stata fatta in casa Potete anche dire
qualcosa di leggermente più sensato però
il punto è un altro dove vi volevo
portare io questa questo pomeriggio è
questa canzone fa schifo o no
Ma come no ma che
bugiardi
Sì non esiste una risposta alternativa
alla terrificante se le vostre orecchie
potessero vomitare lo farebbero Ok ma va
bene va bene perché lo schifo di oggi
non è lo schifo di domani questo mio
simpatico amico che porta in serbo
questo coso questo brano con le casse
che non si sa doveva finire forse se
l'avessi lanciato sarebbe stato meglio
ti saresti reso conto dei tuoi errori No
meglio tenerlo a prendere polvere nel
computer Bravo bravo No fai schifo e
liberatorio io c'ho fatto una carriera
ragazzi quindi figurati
fai schifo e liberatorio quindi non
abbiate paura di fare schifo sono qui
orgogliosamente sul palco del Tex per
dirvi di festeggiare il vostro schifo
avversario è bellissimo e in conclusione
se fossi quello che probabilmente è il
più grande Creator che abbiamo qui in
Italia adesso Direi facendo schifo ogni
giorno di meno vi ringrazio
[Applauso]
[Musica]